maintenant cette fois retrouver jacques
beaucoup candidat socialiste qui donc
battu dès le premier tour par jean
patrick courtois réélu pour un troisième
mandat bonsoir jacques boucaud leur
contexte national contexte au local
comment expliquez vous cette défaite au
premier tour soir
un contexte national bien évidemment
c'est une sanction d'une sanction qu'on
a pris de plein fouet ici à mâcon bon je
note que bon c'est le maire sortant qui
avait bénéficié c'est ni le front
national
me le front de gauche qui deux parties
kiki qui était aussi dans ceux dans ce
combat qui en bénéficiaient donc voilà
effectivement c'est un cetain
le contexte national qui a fait qu'on a
obtenu si peu de voix ce soir 52 %
seulement des mâconnais se sont déplacés
aux urnes aujourd'hui